Going to a job interview can be nerve-wracking, but did you know that your body language can make a huge difference?
From the way you walk into the room to how you say goodbye, your gestures, posture, and voice send powerful messages.
In fact, according to psychologist Albert Morabian's 73855 rule, only 7% of communication comes from words, while 38% is from your tone of voice and 55% is from your body language.
This article will teach you how to use body language to appear confident, trustworthy, and professional in interviews, with practical tips and exercises to practice.
Perfect for young students, professionals in Brazil, or anyone preparing for an English-speaking job interview.
What is body language?
Body language includes your movements, hands, legs and arms, facial expressions, posture, how you sit or stand, and voice, tone and volume.
Using it effectively can help you connect with the interviewer and show you're the right person for the job.
Top 10 Body Language Tips for Interviews Follow these tips to communicate confidence and professionalism.
Walk confidently.
Enter the room with a smile, shoulders back, and steady steps.
Make eye contact with the interviewer to show confidence.
Give a firm handshake.
In English-speaking countries like the UK or USA, a strong handshake shows trust and interest.
Wait for the interviewer to extend their hand first, then shake firmly for two to three seconds.
Smile naturally.
Smile for two to three seconds when meeting the interviewer to appear friendly.
Laugh at their jokes, but not your own, to build rapport.
Control your breathing.
Before the interview, take 10 deep breaths, inhale for 3 seconds, hold for 3, exhale for 3, to stay calm.
During the interview, inhale when asked a question and speak while exhaling for a confident voice.
Maintain eye contact.
Look at the interviewer's eyes for about 70% of the time to show interest.
Every two seconds, shift your gaze to their nose, mouth, or forehead to avoid staring.
Nod and listen actively.
Nod your head gently while the interviewer speaks and use phrases like I see or yes to show you're paying attention.
Keep Palms Up Show your palms facing up when gesturing to appear open and honest.
Hiding your palms can make you seem less trustworthy.
Use Controlled Gestures Use hand gestures to emphasize points, but don't overdo it.
Avoid fidgeting, tapping fingers, or touching your face as these can signal nervousness or dishonesty.
Sit with good posture.
Sit with your back straight, shoulders slightly back, and legs slightly apart, angling your knees toward the interviewer.
Avoid leaning back, which looks lazy, or forward too much, which seems aggressive.
Mirror subtly.
Copy the interviewer's body language, e.g.
placing a hand on their leg, subtly, to build a connection.
Be careful not to make it obvious.